welcome back so there's one more really
neat linear algebra trick I want to tell
you to analyze these linear systems of
equations called the cayley-hamilton
theorem
okay so cayley-hamilton this is an
absolute gem in linear linear algebra
it's not that commonly known again if
you see Hamilton's name you know this is
going to be a big deal okay the
cayley-hamilton theorem is an extremely
elegant way of representing solutions of
X dot equals ax and I'm going to tell
you about this now
so the cayley-hamilton theorem is
extremely simple to state it says that
every square matrix a every square
matrix it's a square matrix every square
matrix a satisfies its own
characteristic equation okay satisfies
its own characteristic and the
characteristic equation is the
eigenvalue equation its own
characteristic or eigen value equation
okay so what do I mean by that well if I
take the equation determinant of s of a
minus lambda I equals 0 this is the
eigenvalue equation this is only true
for special numbers lambda there eigen
values of a if I take this equation
let's say it is lambda to the N plus a n
minus 1 lambda to the N minus 1 plus dot
dot dot plus a 2 lambda squared plus a 1
lambda plus a 0 equals 0 let's say this
is the characteristic polynomial the
roots of which are eigen values of the a
matrix this is remarkable
so cayley-hamilton says if I plug in a
everywhere I see a lambda this is also
satisfied as a matrix equation that so
the a matrix satisfied
it's own characteristic equation so if I
write a n plus little a and last one to
the big matrix a n minus one plus dot
dot dot plus a 2 matrix squared plus a 1
matrix plus a 0 times the identity
matrix that equals 0 for every square
matrix a someone pointed out to me that
this might not actually be true for
every single square matrix a so almost
every matrix a satisfies its own
characteristic equation I don't want to
get into the edge cases where this is
not true you can look this up in a
linear algebra book and find out if this
is true everywhere but basically this is
true for for most matrices ok I think it
might actually be true for every matrix
and so what this means is that a n if I
move all this stuff over to the right
hand side I can say that a N equals some
identity matrix plus some a matrix plus
some a squared matrix
dot dot minus an a n minus 1 to the a n
minus 1 so a n is a linear combination
of all of these basis matrices and that
also means that a to the n plus 1 so
think about if I take a to the n plus 1
I just take all of this stuff times a
this one will be in a to the N term and
I'll just plug all this stuff in for it
so any higher power any a to the kind of
greater than or equal to n power is
going to equal a sum of these alpha J a
to the J from J equals 0 to n minus 1 ok
so every matrix every power of a that's
greater than or equal to n is just the
sum of these first you know these first
n minus 1 powers and the identity this
is really remarkable because what this
allows you to do is take the solution
remember the solution of X dot equals ax
is e to the a T times X NOx and remember
e to the a T equalled identity plus 80
plus a squared T squared over 2 plus dot
dot dot forever
this went on forever there's infinitely
many terms here but what's really
remarkable is after the a to the N and a
to the n plus 1 and a to the n plus 2
terms I can write those as an
honest-to-goodness some of the first the
first terms up to a to the N minus 1 so
this is absolutely remarkable as I can
write this e to the a T instead of an
infinite sum of matrices I can write
this as sum I'm going to write this as
some coefficients I'm going to call it
alpha 0 of T times the identity matrix
plus alpha 1 of T times the a matrix
plus alpha 2 of T a squared plus dot dot
plus alpha n minus 1 of T a to the N
minus 1 period there is this is a finite
sum there's not an infinite sum of terms
here so I've taken all of the higher
terms and I've written them in terms of
these coefficients of lower powers of a
and I've essentially boiled those down
into time varying coefficients of these
basis matrices now this is really
remarkable because this finite sum
representation of e to the a T is going
to allow us to show the equivalence of
controllability and reach ability ok so
in the next segment I'm actually going
to construct using this expression an
equivalence that if this
it's a controllability matrix C remember
this is B a B a squared B dot dot dot up
to a to the n minus 1 B and now you're
starting to see like this only goes up
to n minus 1 this only goes up to n
minus 1 if this has rank n if this is
half full you know if this spans all of
our n I'm going to show you I'm going to
rocked the fact that I can reach any
state okay so we're going to do that in
the next segment but it's built on the
cayley-hamilton theorem it's extremely
extremely useful not just for this but
for lots of other things okay